[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today kre is
with us to start this hour in Houston hi
Kendra how are you I'm doing all right
how are you doing Dave better than we
deserve what's up
Sir okay so I was calling just to get uh
some advice so I am about $61,000 in
debt uh I make about 55 to 62,000 a year
just depending on you know what kind of
jobs we get I am uh I drive a concrete
mixer okay so you know our business is
generally driven by you know what kind
of contracts we did the weather you know
anything can affect anything and
everything can affect uh the paycheck
so I have about $119,000 in student loan
debt uh about $44,000 in credit cards
and the rest is a
$35,000 car loan which I pay about $762
a month for oh you're feeling that yeah
yeah um so I think we found the problem
uh yeah are you upside down on it so
yeah definitely I owe $35,000 and the
car is worth $25,000 2021 Jeep Grand
Cherokee um I got it with no money down
as da would say I got put into a
situation where I got scared and then I
got stupid you
did okay so what kind of condition what
kind of condition is your credit
in uh my credit is now
in worst Condition it's around the mid
500 it was at a the who's the car loan
with um it's with CIG Financial it's
through a company uh through the
dealership AutoNation in uh
Houston
okay all right
um well the net result is you've got a
to sell the car and we have to figure
out how okay I imagine yeah yeah because
the car is killing you I mean it's safe
to say that if you didn't have this car
you probably wouldn't have even called
us yeah definitely and I'm assuming you
don't have any money laying around no
savings nothing so I have I have half of
my baby step one uh the other half will
be going in at the end of this week and
after that no nothing okay so you got
500 bucks are you
married are you
married do we lose no sir I'm not
married okay uh all right um and so
you're you're driving the concrete truck
what 40 hours a
week uh no I generally work anywhere
from 55 to 70 hours a week okay and
that's making the
65,000 yes do you are you're renting a
house or apartment uh we're renting in
an apartment what's the
rent uh $1,100
okay all right so it may take a little
bit but here here's the the the formula
is we got to come up with 10 grand fast
mhm and that means beans and rice rice
and beans all the OT you can pick up or
side hustles you can pick up if you're
not picking up OT all right and you know
I want you to sign up for everything
they'll let you drive anything you can
do and beans and rice rice and beans no
restaurants no vacations no nothing that
we get 10 grand to cover the hole that
in and then you sell the car and cover
the 10 grand get you a $1000
car okay do you have anything else you
can sell anything associated with the
business that you don't need need uh no
uh other than this car honestly I've
been a minimalist for a very long time
uh I don't really until you met the
Grand Cherokee yeah yeah exactly that
that was the first and worst big thing
I've ever uh gotten in my life yeah and
I'm sorry you're stuck in this but
really you got to have the 10 grand the
other option and I don't think it will
work but I'll put it out here just cuz
it is a slight possibility you might
slide over there to auton nation and say
guys um I'm about to get repossessed
here cuz I'm having real problems with
this
car and uh I need you guys to let me
sign a note and pay payments on the 10
grand and uh take and let me sell the
car for 25 now who said the car is worth
25 where'd you get that information uh
so I what on Kelly Blue Book got the
quote private private
sale yes not trade in no trade in okay
all right so uh they might say we'll
give you X number of dollars for the car
and let you sign a note for the
difference and if you pay $700 a month
on $110,000 you can get it paid off
pretty quick
MH right and I let me tell you I I give
you less than a 10% chance of that
working I was going to say what's the
likelihood of that but I would haul my
butt down there and sit in front of them
and and try
it right in person not on the phone and
not by email drive up with the car sit
down talk to the financial manager in
person and say I'm screwed here and
don't blame them you're you're not
you're not a victim you signed up for
this right but don't go in there and go
you guys did me wrong that's not the
point we know they did you wrong but
that's not the point so if he tries it
and it doesn't work then you got to come
up with 10 grand is there a situation
where you would say listen if I can get
a credit card for that 10 grand yeah
yeah I'd take a credit card for the 10
grand cuz I would rather you ow 10 grand
on a credit card than 35 on a Grand
Cherokee that's what I'm
saying um I don't know how I would go
about getting a 10 grand on a credit
card I don't either not with a 550 I
don't but um you know I mean it could be
that your credit union will loan it to
you but I doubt
it right that's why I was asking about
your credit but if you got a credit
union that you've got a long-standing
history with and the guy knows you in
there you might go in there and get 10
grand to cover the hole M or 11 Grand
which is one to buy a car with you get
your a little a little garage sale car
to get back and forth to work right yeah
or maybe if you get rid of that 30 get
the 30 get rid of 25 of the 35 you can
deal with the other 10 pretty quick okay
so if I if I were to pause the baby
steps until I can come up with like a
$2,000 for a little cash car and then
sell the $25,000 car yep you got the 10
grand difference but the difference is
that's that's where the problem is is
that 10 grand difference you can't sell
your car until you can get the title for
it and you have to pay them 35 to get
the title right right right right right
okay that's why I keep trying to come up
with a 10 grand
somewhere listen even if you can get and
don't go down there and let them screw
you and put you into another deal oh no
definitely not no more deals with these
people yeah I'm not trying to get any
more notes any more any more debt I'm
not trying we're going to help you out
by selling you a $20,000 car no you
don't need a $20,000 car you need out of
the $35,000 car
completely right no debt that's what we
need and then if you don't have any
payments when we clear this mess up I
mean you can then you can deal with the
other two things pretty quick you can
knock out $4,000 in credit card $19,000
student loan cuz you ain't going
stinking $750 payment anymore right
right so that this is that's why we
spent the entire time talking to you
about getting out of this car well
that's the lesson the problem is in the
car almost every time man we used to
call this the sell the car show yeah
yeah Dave my my dog is ill sell the car
Dave my marriage is struggling sell the
car it was the answer to everything sell
the car sell the car create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life